of all the things I've seen on the
battlefields of the frontier the pilot
is the true dominant force fast and
agile
graceful yet devastating perceptive
resourceful and relentless a pilot sees
the world differently
sheer walls become flanking routes
pilots fight differently
experienced and deception and maneuver
even overwhelming odds shift in their
favor but what truly separates the pilot
from all the drugs and machines of the
battlefield is the bond between a pilot
and a Titan
when links to our tightness a pilot can
only be stopped by overwhelming force or
an equal
[Music]
the frontier has been the only home I've
ever known for years our lands have been
destroyed by the IMC forcefully taking
our resources polluting and destroying
our planets and killing us off if we try
to resist despite recent victories at
Demeter and beyond we have a long way to
go before the IMC is defeated now I
serve as a rifleman in the militia
fighting to free the frontier I'm a long
way from becoming a pilot
when that day comes
I hope I can live up to the honor
you